[Music]
please welcome pamela anderson
to everlasting love
we have recently come into possession of
a piece of material
hiya kittens and here we go again
today is the start of a new chapter for
us you texted a guy without my input
so what do we think of jules opening
here how did that make you all feel bad
the road's closed i opened up the
visitors center for some folks and
waited out there
are here till the storm clears
oh it's gonna be a long night
what is your
name stanton carlisle
are you a true medium yes i am
can you read minds yes i can under the
right circumstances
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
while governments wait for orders
our people take action
welcome to the club
time to dance
[Music]
diana
they can't change you have to change
[Music]
there's no hope for me not with them
fight them
you are your own weapon
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone i knew had heard the rumors
about this incredible young piano player
from
of all places montreal
back then i didn't even know they had
black people in canada
there's gonna be imitations there's
gonna be things that are derivative but
it will never be oscar
oh my god this is gonna be huge
everything erin there's something i
haven't told you came down to this
moment
i just got out of rehab i'm so glad
you're back we're gonna party like when
tom was still with the patriots i can i
want all the booze and all the drugs all
at the same time you want to come in for
a cup of tea it's not blow but it's all
i have
we are back out on the road like only
idol can do we fall in love with their
stories
relive the music
the moves
and the magic of dirty dancing
as eight celebrities compete on the
dance floor
[Music]
i built this company
with some dirt and the american dream
now my legacy rests in my family's hands
wants a taste
we can't go back to africa so we'll make
our own africa town that spirit of my
ancestors that spirit lives in me
[Music]
how this started out as a simple car
accident
then now you two are back together again
i think this is murder
big allegations for a small town
[Music]
it was an accident what kind of an
accident
suv went over leon's ridge we have to
get down there we had to save him what
happened in that car what are you not
telling me
leaving permanently whatever
complications may be ahead we will face
them together
[Music]
you